merci pour la mauricie allez-vous alors
moi je vais je vais plutôt vous raconter
des histoires que je préfère des choses
très théorique mais des travaux
commencés je demande est ici s'il ya les
gens qui se sentent prêts maintenant à
se lancer dans l'entrepreneuriat si vous
allez en la maintenant aujourd'hui
ok ok provient est alors moins je vais
pas vous faire un cours sur la sarthe
michel il fonds d'investissement je veux
simplement obligé les trois histoires
et la première a commencé là dessus en
fait moi j'ai toujours rêvé d'être dj
enfin je sais pas vous mais comme en
soirée les gens qui mixe ali ambiance
tout le monde et énergie incroyable et
moi j'avais envie d'être sept personnes
devant faire danser tout le monde puisse
voir que la fait quoi et en fin de
compte je commençais à en parler autour
de moi j'ai déjà vu toucher à ça et puis
j'ai eu la chance de partir en chine à
shanghai où j'ai vécu un petit moment et
j'en parlais autour de moi j'étais pas
dire que j'aime mieux tester ça j'ai
commencé à en parler à des joueurs des
clubs je commence à en parler la mise à
dix quinze jours j'ai téléphone qui
sonne à ma prodi puis un jour un ami
qu'il allait aussi dans celles qui
m'avaient l'equidium iliad qui s'est
décommandé un dj dans un gros part à
shanghai est ce que tu voudrais pas dû
prendre la place bien sûr je suis là je
pourrai est-il enfin aux cobras et
méchoui et du coup j'ai la dame qui
m'appelle 2
du bar et puis il explique que il va
falloir que je lui envoie un lien sommes
cloud pour montrer un peu ce que je sais
faire alors pour resituer le contexte
moi j'ai jamais touché de platines à ce
moment là je connais pas trop
musique et puis ce que je fais c'est
tout le dit je vais utiliser mon réseau
commence à appeler les gens autour de
moi et je suis dit partout mais sur une
très bonne amie à cette dame là qu'ils
m'expliquent tous ses goûts musicaux en
un quart d'heure je suis un socle de ses
cinq meilleures musiques j'essaie de les
mixer un peu près sûr le seul club sur
sa place je suis ok pour vendredi soir
ou bien mercredi du coup je me mets à
travailler je commence à apprendre sur
youtube je fais des petits shows sur le
papier gysi de l'apprendre chez les amis
qui sont lus à la musique documents des
pluies trop vidéo cliquée bouton et
j'arrive en fait le jour où je vis et
giant peu plus tôt à 16 heures je me
rends compte que pour les platines il
faut un truc un peu spécial dans l'est
de son cas soit m quelques photos d'un
moment je trouve en chou liège pour tous
mais au final on arrive à faire quatre
heures de cette qui se transforme en six
heures de selle payeur et ont fait une
soirée incroyable de genève et par
ailleurs vous propose après les
présidents du club et puis là j'ai
organisé hier soir a beaucoup joué cette
histoire déjà deux saisons du plaisir
mais parce qu en fait c'est un mix de
plein de choses au début il ya deux mois
m et puis les collections et avec
l'entourage autour de moi qui a fait que
on a eu en fait un besoin qui est
remonté de stieg et là qui étaient
absents on a pensé à moi sont
actualisées de la motivation la lentille
et puis j'étais prêt à travailler pour
ça
et en fait pour moi c'est ça si vous
voulez la définition entrepreneur c'est
juste un cocktail de choses étonnantes
comme ça et la clé ce qui va déclencher
ce lot pérès qui va le lancer ses
nausées simplement ce nom se lancer se
dire oui oui j'en suis capable ouais je
pourra alors faire et oui j'aime
lancement alors que je conseille aux
gens souvent dit l'élève on note
beaucoup de raisons en fait pourquoi je
veux me lancer je les ai cité allez vous
allez on dirait même si j'aimerais faire
des trucs mais je suis fatigué mais en
fait c'est parce qu'on ne rentre pas une
idée ce qu'on demande c'est un marché et
c'est une motivation c'est de s'inclure
dans quelque chose d'avoir une
motivation et d'aller chercher le
faisons
je raconte une autre histoire en fait un
roman je n'étais dans plusieurs musées
et puis j'étais passionné par le du coup
je commence à regarder les choses sur
l'impression de chocolat en 3d je
découpe le laser en plein de choses et
je retrouve du coup un jour a rencontré
quelqu'un qui travaille au marketing de
chez rbs qui avait un besoin de cadeaux
client est offert une somme de
conversation le jard hier à les proposer
en fait une offre pour faire des
chocolats personnalisé avec des textures
de peau de crocodile donc ça c'est des
négociations qui ont pris un an et demi
avant ceci m
mais hermès est devenu le client et du
coup je suis partie au vietnam sur un
scooter pour aller chercher les fèves de
cacao trouver des personnes pour
produire le chocolat et puis aussi
construire tout process pour faire du
chocolat réalisées et donc on a eu un
respect plein de clients après est en
fait ce que je raconte ici c'est que moi
je salue je suis à mes rayons disant je
veux faire du chocolat en 3d par contre
j'avais ce milieu là j'allais ce marché
et je me suis mis dans ce marché je me
suis connecté et en fait on a trouvé un
besoin et on les a confondus simplement
semble y a pas besoin d'avoir dit qu'au
départ il faut juste la médiation
ensuite ce qui ressort souvent séché
d'affaires alors là je m'appelle compte
ainsi wayne je suis pas le faire je la
mutation que je sais pas faire j'ai
jamais fait mélantois en fait c'est pas
la question la question c'est est ce que
je vais faire est ce que je vais vous
donner l'énergie est ce que je vais
m'entourer de personnes qui sont prêtes
à m'accompagner pour le faire pour la
conter une histoire
encore une fois en fait la première
entente parce que j'ai traité dans la
télémédecine donc c'était en
2017 cette fin 2016 ne s'est pas encore
tue tout connu à l'époque et j'ai été
responsable technique de l'entreprise et
jamais une application mobile je n'ai
jamais duchassin et pourtant ils étaient
trois ans s'est lancée la cne on savait
pas faire et on l'a fait on a lancé une
application jeu au final la joie qu'on a
eue quand elles étaient référencées sur
l'app store parce que c'est un chemin
difficile surtout prendre une
application betting et enfin compte le
la clé encore une fois c'est de
s'entourer de personnes d'avoir la
motivation et de secours sis et si vous
n'avez pas faire un site web peut-être
que la première étape celle de l'ancien
groupe facebook et vous répondez déjà
besoin y a pas besoin d'aller chercher
les choses très techniques pour répondre
à un besoin qui est sous la dent
alors du coup quand je dis c'est pas de
faire mais je vais faire elles vont se
retrouver dans des situations on parle
beaucoup la grosse traçage de l'ancêtre
sujets blancs siège là dessus mais rien
de concret avec le problème c'est défend
les divisions qui est très loin à très
long terme et comme cette vision est
longue et lente et on a du mal à trouver
les systèmes qui nous feront et la
sédition et dans vos restes hâtif et
donc des fois on se retrouve dans une
situation diable si jamais les démolit
réveillant le pape et la question en
fait c'est pas l'idée ou la millions c
est ce que je suis prêt à faire les
équipes l'exécution ou avant la
grossesse pour arriver in fine et à
cette idée par exemple je prends
toujours l'exemple de la voiture volante
la voiture ou l'autre on en parle ça va
mieux rappeler d'ailleurs y avait des
choses qui sont indépendants de la nuit
mais la clé leurs urnes l'an passé
répondre à un besoin de mobilité
d'accord c'est légal c'est une personne
d'un point a à un point b mais le besoin
qu'on dit et on peut y répondre de plein
de manières différentes par des moyens
inscrits un bureau une voiture une photo
mh on peut répondre par des services
l'upr itx polge les immeubles est en
fait déjà si on est dans cette situation
on répond à un besoin on génère du
revenu on génère des ventes grâce à
répondre à ce besoin on peut lancer des
projets loppement qui nous font arriver
à cette vision future et donc la
combattre en sortir il ya plein d'autres
encore j'ai une idée je vais vraiment
turbo mais ce que tu l'as fait sa
mission est ce que on s'est mis dans
cette dynamique là pour y arriver donc
il faut pas rester statique faut
simplement itérer
est en fait si vous voulez alors ça
c'est pas nul pour le sidaction
mais c'est ce que je voulais dire parce
que une fois qu'on a passé toutes ces
étapes du concile asie je me lance il ya
une clé qui est importante je pense et
que jean-loup mentionnait elle nourrit
aujourd'hui c'est l'association
l'association quelque part c'est un
mariage plus plus c'est beaucoup plus
d'engagement qu'un mariage parce qu'on
aille vers un engagement économique donc
je dis pas qu'il faut pas s'associer
avec quelqu'un mais au contraire parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on va plus loin et
qu'on est plus fort par contre il faut
faire très attention dans la sélection
sociale et issac être sûr qu'on est
aligné sur les valeurs est sur la route
on aimerait aller ensemble a forcément
sur un projet fariner nature de tangible
mais au moins sur le process est ce qu
on veut partager la bouteille cette
personne est ce qu'on est prêt à lui
faire confiance et ça c'est les places
celles qui feront qu'on serait capable
d'avoir une hypothèque à durer dans le
même temps le train
à une chose aussi que j'aimerais
partager avec vous c'est sur le bazar et
faire un peu de physique par les armes
mais je pense que entendre quand bart
bass cette entreprise c'est aussi la
protection de la planète et l'humanité
pour moi je pense que si
pour oddo passe de tout nouveau projet
entrepreneurial et que c'est un must ram
c'est pas une question seuil et protéger
la planète côté j'ai l'écosystème et
protéger les femmes et les hommes quand
son sens au projet entrepreneurial
alors pour être honnête avec vous j'ai
oublié un point
quand j'ai commencé à parler de
l'entrepreneuriat les choses qui faisait
que qu'on ne se pas se forcer
c'est le manque de légitimité
et moi je suis passé par là et là ce
soir c'est encore par la fête quoi il
n'est ce pas appelé pour me dire qu'est
ce que tu voudrais bien venir faire à
tête d'autres pourparlers
entrepreneuriat ben je suis pas trop
senti légitime pourquoi moi plutôt qu'un
autre bienvenue dans notre entrepreneur
qui sont beaucoup plus que ces soins que
moi et puis même vous dans votre réseau
est là mais les travaux en colère alors
pourquoi venir ici pour vous parler et
après le but ultime est souvent je
raconte toujours les mêmes histoires aux
gens sur le entrepreneuriale fait d'oser
donc peut-être que ça sera un bon moyen
ce soir de proposer le synthétiser et du
coup je me suis fait confiance et tu dis
allez c'est bon je me lance du jeu
faisant vous alors juste parce que ça
roule impact pour aller au bout de la
démarche est une bonne démonstration
je m'en excuse d'ailleurs à l'équipe
organisatrice
j'étais ses stats vierge et christophe
il ya deux heures avant de rentrer en
salle et c'était pour vous montrer en
fait plus que le fait de lancer deux
semaines en moins et diaye d'aller au
contact ça permet de sortir des choses
et je sors jean moulin bac comme ça et
puis put plus que de se faire confiance
et aussi l'idée de faire confiance aux
autres et le sujet ce soir sur le pet
c'est la collection et je crois que
c'est vraiment fondamental dans tout le
projet si vous voulez trouver un projet
sous les routes en a besoin sur voulez
vous lancer ça passe d'abord par la
connexion aux autres et la connexion aux
autres c'est parler autour de vous
fâchez pas là vous êtes dans un profit
peut-être que vous a jamais vraiment
occupé l'essentiel ou d'oise un set vous
ai jamais parlé et en fait c'est si
connexion là c'est le fait d'y aller et
défense se sont pas légitimes aussi pour
aller voir quelqu'un on parlait tout à
l'heure une linkedin on va avoir des
gens sur qui on va aussi les approcher
parce que ils sont trop forts et vos
premiers à visiter rome en fait on se
rend compte que dans la vraie vie les
gens sont d'un prêt a ouvert la porte et
à transmettre donc il faut y aller faut
pas se juger et puis faut juste se
connecter donc n'hésitez pas à mobilité
halliche issa et de venir me parler
aussi leur a pas de ceux ci ce sera un
plaisir donc du coup je suis resté
séance par un sens elle est ce qu'il y
en a parmi eux ou qu'ils sont prêts à
entreprendre et reste français
et les récits la démonstration merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]